okay so you guys have been asking me a
bunch of hot button issues so we want to
do these short videos where I basically
explained what I think of these things
these are completely unscripted this is
just coming off the top of my head as is
so one of the things that you guys have
asked me a lot about is what do I think
of the refugee situation in Europe and
in America and I get a ton of email
about this you know I mentioned once on
the show I think it was with Douglas
Murray something about the refugee
situation in Sweden or actually he
probably brought it up and then I
followed up with something and I've been
getting a ton of messages emails and
Facebook messages from people in Sweden
that are extremely concerned about
what's going on with the refugee
situation there and they feel like
there's this influx of people and we
were hearing about this obviously not
just in Sweden but we're hearing about
this in Belgium and in France and in the
UK and all these places and we're
hearing about it here in the United
States although we haven't left let many
people in so before I get to the
specifics of that go I should say that
you know it's we shouldn't be lost on
any of us that we here in America are a
nation of refugees right so unless you
were a Native American and we didn't
treat them that well right the pilgrims
in treat them that well unless you were
a Native American or your ancestors were
brought here as slaves then pretty much
the rest of us were immigrants right not
necessarily refugees but immigrants but
a lot of them were were refugees so we I
think as a general rule we should always
try to be as welcoming as the system can
possibly allow so that being said and I
mentioned this in the video that I did
about gun control I don't have great
trust in the government so now we do
have a problem with radical Islam right
now right it is a problem okay just
saying that I know that makes people
great but it is a problem I'm not
talking about Muslims I'm talking about
radicalism which is a tiny percentage of
these people right now if we just are
letting in massive amounts of refugees
without a scanning and a screening
process that makes sense because our
government is pretty dysfunctional right
as we're finding out the San Bernardino
shooters the woman only came here a
couple of years ago on like a fiance
visa or something so if you don't trust
government to do this stuff effectively
then yeah we're going to have a problem
so that's why the refugee question is so
bizarre and that's why it's happening in
such a bizarre fashion at the same time
as guns because what's happening is
you're going to the fear Center
especially for the people on the right
you're going wait a minute they want to
take away our guns and they want to let
in people that are going to kill us now
of course it's not that simple most of
these people the vast vast majority are
fleeing awful terrorism and bombings and
all this stuff and probably just want to
come here to try to live a decent life
at the same time it is possible that
Isis could take advantage of that or
some of these people will even be
radicalized here partly because people
like Trump will say all Muslims are bad
so it is extremely complex and
unfortunately we're not really good at
these extreme complex situations in
America but one thing that I do find
particularly interesting is that we know
that the European governments are taking
in plenty of people right we're figuring
out what to do here we know that
unfortunately that a lot of time the
Muslim immigrants and here I'm talking
about the people there's an integration
problem right and you could say it's
partly the society it's partly the
people whatever it is I'm sure it's
different for each country but you know
one thing that's particularly
interesting here is that Saudi Arabia
has three million air-conditioned units
units for three million people that are
only used five days a year you can
google this I'm not making this up
they're used five days a year for the
people that go on the Hajj to Mecca
these things are sitting empty on at a
country that literally almost shares a
border with Syria not quite but but not
that far off from Syria and no one says
well why doesn't Saudi Arabia do
anything right or why don't any of the
Gulf states that are that are incredibly
wealthy right the United Arab Emirates
and Qatar and all this stuff why don't
they do anything to I think everybody if
we live in this this world the small
world right then everybody should try to
be apart but unfortunately we dumb down
debate here where it's either if you
don't like them your asus then if you
love them then you're trying to destroy
America guess what not that simple yeah